Hey, Logic. How we doing, bro?
>> What's up, man?
>> I'm good. How are you?
>> I'm good, man. You you you know you
going to get in trouble, right?
>> Why am I going to get in trouble?
>> For for being on the panel with me.
>> Well, go watch the brothers back, bro.
Go watch the brothers back. You know
what I mean?
>> Well, if they if they come for you, man,
I I got you, man. I got you, man. You
know, we we got you back.
>> Yeah. You're going to be pushing more
deep pushing me more deeper into it. No,
we're doing all right.
>> Pretty good, man.
>> Yeah. Well, this this hadith that you
brought up is interesting. Um I think
there's just a few questions I need to
ask you on it.
>> Sure.
>> When I've been reading it, right?
Obviously, like from your paradigm, you
believe obviously Jesus was crucified,
right? And he he was on the he was on
the cross and he said these words,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> You also believe the five points of um
the punctures on Jesus, right?
>> The five what?
>> Where he got where he got nailed, you
know, the nails the five points of um
the wounds, right? Obviously one on the
side, two in the hands and two at the
feet, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Mentioned in Matthew 27:35,
um also in Mark 15:24, Luke 23:33, John
19:18, all confirm this, right? And John
19:34 confirms the puncture on the side,
right? Where's had gone? It's um
disappeared.
Sorry. Um I was just checking my
messages cuz I'm expecting some guests.
So please uh bear with me but continue
with your your point though.
>> Yeah. So obviously when I'm reading that
hadith I can see the point you're trying
to make that you know it's clearly
pointing towards Jesus peace be upon
him. Right. Um obviously there were
there were a time where prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him also got attacked by
the people of Tai. um and he went some
through something similar and you know
maybe when he did um say this you know
it could be pointing towards Jesus peace
be upon him or you know any other
prophet the only question the reason I'm
asking you about this is because
obviously as within your paradigm Jesus
peace be upon him and he got nailed to
the cross through his hands
>> Mhm. Right. And through his feet. And
then he was strung up. He was put up on
a high position where he was literally
hanging off the cross. Right.
>> Yep.
>> Um and he said these words. Is that
right?
>> Yes.
>> Right. Cuz obviously within within this
within this um hadith, it clearly says,
"And he was wiping the blood off his
face and saying, "Oh Lord, forgive my
people as they do not know."
>> Yep. So clearly if he's strung up to a
cross pierced in his wrists or his hands
either
>> right and um pierced through his feet
with nails big nails going through flesh
obviously that was his human flesh. So
any human that is hanging probably 13 14
15t high you know on the way of his
wrists you know one thing he can't be
doing is wiping blood off his face.
>> Well it doesn't say that he was wiping
it with his hands. You can wipe you can
wipe blood off your face with your
shoulder if you're stretched out.
>> So
>> like this. Look. Look. I can do it.
>> You see I'm wiping my hands. My I'm not
even moving my arms. They're stretched
out wide and I'm wiping my face.
>> Are you serious, brother?
>> Yeah. I'm serious. Wiping doesn't
require hands.
>> All right. Okay. That's um if that's
your I mean the way I'm looking at it,
clearly it's someone that's been injured
and he's wiping the blood off his face.
>> Yeah. What does it say? Does it say how
he wiped his his face?
>> It's just hard to believe if somebody's
up there who's in that state as you
believe he's being beat up. He's being
>> could
somebody could Jesus who is stretched
out wide use his shoulder to wipe his
face.
>> I mean you just think about all your
body weight on your wrists and you're
literally on your wrists and your body's
hanging down. I'm just asking is it
logically consistent that Jesus who is
stretched out in pain nailed to a cross
can wipe his face with his shoulder?
>> Maybe, maybe not. I mean, it just
depends what kind of a state a person is
in, I suppose.
>> So, it's possible. So, it doesn't rule
it out.
>> No, it doesn't rule it out. I wouldn't
say it rules it out 100%, but for me,
that's just difficult to believe.
>> Well, that would be Jesus in that
position. So these are these are these
are two options we can go with this.
Okay. One um what I just showed you that
you know um Jesus can just wipe his face
with his shoulder you know cuz it
doesn't say how he wipes his face. It
just says he wipes his the blood off his
face. So he can wipe his face off with
his shoulders as his arms are stretched
out wide. That's one option cuz that so
that doesn't eliminate you know Jesus
being crucified. Secondly, um it just
shows demonstrates that the that
Muhammad doesn't get the story
completely right. So, as he's
referencing the story of Jesus and this
happening to him, he doesn't get it
fully right. So,
>> and obviously there's a there's a few
more. There's Muslim as well and there's
another one as well within within the
same
>> Yeah, they all say the same exact thing.
>> Yeah, similar. There's um they're
similar. Yeah. Um but this is what I
mean. For me, it's kind of I can
understand where you're coming from, you
know, but for me it's kind of difficult
to get, you know, you know, to
understand the fact that, you know, it's
just I suppose being in that state and
being in that position. Um,
>> and you know, last thing you're going to
be think about is, you know, wiping
blood off your face and saying phrases.
>> Yeah. Again, like like I said, um I just
demonstrated to you how how it's
possible for somebody to wipe their face
if their arms are stretched out. It's
not hard at all. And then two, um,
two also it'll show it'll demonstrate
that Muhammad got the story. It'll show
that Muhammad got the story wrong. If
that's
>> Yes. You know, you say wiping the blood
of his face, right? A part of his face.
You're talking about the full face,
right? Clearly, you believe he had
something around his forehead which was
making him bleed. Is that right?
>> He has a crown on his head. On his
forehead that's made of what?
>> What's the crown of his head?
>> What was Yeah. What was that crown made
of?
>> You don't know? No, I'm asking you. Was
it like some sort of spikes, right?
>> Thorns.
>> Thorns. Yeah, sorry. Yeah. So, it were
thorns and obviously he was bleeding
from his forehead. Probably coming
dribbling down his forehead. Maybe going
down all over his face. He was bleeding
all over his face. He got beat up. He
was punched on, whipped, slapped. He was
bleeding all over his face. So the point
the point the point here is blessed
faith is that there is no one that fits
this description and that said these
words other than Jesus and him on the
cross. That's that's the point. All
right. That's fine. I'm just going to
have to look into it a little bit more.
I mean like I says for me um just the
wiping the blood wiping off the face and
all that is it's just um kind of nodded
and open overall for me it's just so
>> that's just the whole crucifixion
>> believe believe in the crucifixion
>> exactly there it is it's that's what it
is you're you're a Muslim who has a
presupposition against the crucifixion
that's what's making this hard for you
it's not that this logically doesn't
follow but you're a Muslim and you have
presuppositions,
a bias against Jesus being crucified. So
everything that's in you, you're kind of
trying to think of way, oh, well, this
maybe not fit this, it doesn't fit this,
but it doesn't it doesn't it doesn't
work. Obviously, everything that we
have, the only thing we have where we
have a prophet in history saying these
words, saying these words is when Jesus
is on the cross. That's it. That's the
only time we have it. So
>> yeah, that's that's you know that's I've
seen the words. Um I've read the verse
in I think it's in Luke. Yeah.
>> Yep. Luke Luke 34.
>> It says for me
>> for me I'm going to have to look a
little bit more into the hadith and see
uh what else comes out of it. And yeah
that's it really. Thank you. Thank you
for that. But besides like I said for me
like you said I'm a Muslim. For me the
crucifixion thing is a bit more you know
difficult believe you know God would do
that to such a
>> why
>> to such a man.
>> Why?
>> Yeah
>> because the simple fact that it's God
himself why would God
>> But you don't believe that?
>> Why would God the almighty the all
powerful need blood?
>> Mhm. For me that's just too difficult to
understand.
>> That being diff this is what I don't get
when you guys say that something is too
difficult for you to understand and so
therefore you reject it because
literally blessed faith when I ask you
guys about questions regarding Allah and
his nature you guys openly admit Allah
we don't know the how it's too difficult
for us to understand but we affirm and
accept it because this is what Allah has
said or has taught or the prophet has
said. So you are open and willing to
accept things that are too difficult for
you to understand and grasp. But when it
comes to Christianity, you reject stuff
because you're saying it's too difficult
for you to grasp. That is so
inconsistent. You get what I'm saying?
>> Right. You know, I get what you're
saying. That's that's understandable. We
can go through that as well. But for me,
in the sense when I'm saying to you,
right, Avery, that it's difficult for me
to grasp, right? Do you know do you know
when I read verses like Matthew 26:39
for example or Luke 22:42 where Jesus is
literally begging for his life right
obviously we don't believe Jesus is God
you know I'm look at it from my paradigm
don't look at it from your paradigm just
for a second right
>> why why do you guys why do you guys like
stop that halfway he's begging for the
father's will to be done isn't he
>> yes but he's also begging for the cup to
be lifted
>> he says if it's possible let not this
cup pass from me but not my will let
your will be done according to Jesus's
prayer what does he want more
>> well as far as I know if you're asking
me for according to Jesus's prayer he
wants he he doesn't he also does not
want to get crucified
>> that's not what I asked you I asked what
does he want
>> God's will for God's will thank you
exactly so if he's asking for the cup to
be lifted however not my will father let
your will be done he's begging
for his the father's will to be done.
And when you and and again, you're a
Muslim, so you're disconnected from all
of this. When you read the prophets, it
literally tells you what the will of the
Lord is. It literally says in Isaiah
53:10,
it says that it is the will of the Lord
to crush him, to he has put him to
grief, to make his soul an offering for
guilt. That's what it says. Yeah.
>> So when we have the prophets and already
telling us what God is going to do and
what his plan is, why are we so shocked
when we see it come to pass? Come to
pass. So you know the thing is right
this I'll explain to you right I'll tell
you why why it's so difficult right? So
obviously I've just heard what you're
about to say. Right. So you know like
when you're saying you know obviously
he's doing God's will right that's okay.
I get that. I get that from your
paradigm. Right. Again when you're
reading the verse it says going going a
little further he fell with his face to
the ground and prayed. Right. This is in
the NIV. Right. If possible be taken
from me. Yet not as I will but as you
will. Right. Basically what he means is
if if it's not your will father that's
fine. And I want to go with your will. I
get where you're coming from. But he
also says, "If it is possible, may this
cup be taken if it is possible, may this
cup be taken from me." But he's still
happy to do God's will like you say,
right? So if it is possible, which
within God's paradigm, anything is
possible. Do we agree with that?
>> Is it it's impossible for God to fail
and lie, isn't it?
>> It's impossible for God for God to do a
lot of things. That's fine. But I'm just
saying if it is if if God wants to lift
the cup, can God lift the cup?
>> The reason the reason why that that is
impossible is because God has foretold
and said what he's going to do. And so
if he lifts the cup, then that'll make
him out to be a liar.
>> If God himself who sets all the rules,
if God himself
who
>> you're saying that God, you're saying
that God can go back on his word. You're
saying God can go back on his word is
what you're saying.
>> No, it's not about going God going back
on his word. It's about God forgiving
sin.
>> No. Can God go back? Bless. Can Can God
go back on his word?
>> No. God if God wants to say something on
his word, that's fine.
>> Okay. So, if God said
if God said that he's going to use the
Messiah and make his soul an offering
for guilt, if God said that that was
that's what he's going to do, and then
he doesn't do that, then that means that
he's a liar and he went back on his
word, right?
>> Yeah. Okay, that's fine. That's
understandable. But did God need to do
that?
>> We needed him to do that. We We needed
him to do that because without Christ,
without Christ, we're suffering that
punishment that he took. We're suffering
that death that he took on. We're facing
the wrath of God for our sin.
>> So, would you say, right? Yeah.
>> To save us. Christ comes in in our
place.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, every would you say that
it's fair on an honest note? Just put
religion aside for a second, right?
Would you say it's fair for Jesus, peace
be upon him, to be crucified, unalived,
beaten, bruised, humiliated, a sinless
person who you believe is a sinless man
who's a blessing from God, right? To be
cursed on a cross like that, would you
would you say that is fair? Just forget
religion. Just put religion aside for
one second. Just think about Jesus, he's
a man. That's it. I can't. Is that fair?
>> I can't because Jesus is not just a man.
He's God.
>> No, but I'm saying if if it is if it is
just a man, is that
>> if it was just a man? No. If it was just
a man, a mere man, no. It is impossible
for somebody to take on the sin of
someone else. This is why it Jesus is
not just a man, but he's God in the
flesh who has the ability and the value
of life to be able to carry on the sins
of mankind, past, present, and future.
It couldn't be a creature to do that.
God had to do it. So therefore, this is
why it's amazing that God loves us
enough to come down from his throne,
meet us where we are, come down in silly
uh in the likeness of silly sinful
flesh, uh feeble, weak flesh that can
bleed, that can tire, that can grow
hungry. He comes and represents mankind
on our behalf because he has the ability
to do it and because he loves us enough
to do it. That's that's that's the only
way is if Jesus is God. So with this
being said, we have God coming in the
flesh which is why it makes sense when
Jesus says for example blessed Jesus
says no one takes my life from me. I lay
it down on my own accord. I have the
authority to lay it down. I have the
authority to pick it back up again.
What? No man can say this. No mere
prophet can say this. That no one can
take my life. That I can I'm the one who
lays down my life and I'm going to I
have the authority to take it back up
again. No mere creature can make that
claim. So when I see that God is the one
who came and took that responsibility
upon himself when he didn't have to but
he chose to because he loved us. He then
goes on and represents mankind on our
behalf and takes on his own wrath. Takes
under the punishment that we deserve for
us and then rises again 3 days later in
authority so that we can be reconciled
back to God, walk in newness of life, be
born again. That's the only way man can
uh face salvation, reach salvation.
That's it. Is if God reached down to us.
So that's the gospel.
>> Yeah. So why wouldn't God's mercy just
be enough? Why? Why does Because God is
just one second. I just listen to every
one second. One second. I just listen to
you. Right. Yeah. Sorry. So sorry. Yeah.
Okay. But what I'm saying is basically
right. Jesus is the son of God. You
believe, right? He is God himself,
right? He's come down to earth himself,
right? He's fully man. He's fully God,
right? He's the son of the father who is
also God, right? Then this God on earth
has to go through his mission which is
to be crucified for our sins, right?
Live a life, go through go, you know,
live a life, not want to go through with
what's going to happen to him. Obviously
the human side which you believe, right?
Then he has to be literally the devil
himself has to be used to carry out the
works of the crucifixion through his
children. Right? Then this man has to go
through this. Then he has to be
crucified, tortured, etc. Then he has to
be strung up and then he has to also
scream out to his father, you know, why
have you why have you deserted me?
Right.
>> He's quoting he's quoting he's quoting a
psalm that points to his crucifixion
when he says that by the way.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yes, I'm 22. Yeah. And
then he's um you know,
>> so so there's a reason why he does that.
Notice notice how you're giving me the
shot these shotgun points. I'm going
have to stop you here cuz what you're
trying to do is you're trying to
shotgun. I don't know why you're doing
that.
>> He quotes Psalm 22.
>> Okay. So he he quotes he he does all of
this. He quotes Psalm 22 that points to
his crucifixion that says, "They pierce
my hands and my feet and they divide my
garments among them and and for my
clothing they cast lots." Exactly what
happens to Jesus on the on the cross.
the the the Isaiah 53 says that he's
full of dis uh he's acquainted with
grief and acquainted with sorrow and
he's carrying our sorrows and despair
upon himself. So when we see him crying
in the garden of Gethsemane or crying
out on the cross, it already told us
this is going to happen. It already told
us that he's going to be acquainted with
grief and sorrow. Our sorrows are going
to be placed on him. So why does it
surprise you? Because it surprises me
because if Jesus is God himself and that
same God is the father himself, why does
he why does God need to put another God
through that? What what my point is
>> why does God why why does God come down
himself in
>> why does God need to put well why does
yeah God need to put himself for me
that's you know let's face I I already
told I already told you why do you do
you believe that God is just
>> yes
>> you believe he's just okay will he sweep
your sin under the rug
>> if he's just will he sweep your sin
under the rug
>> but would you would you say would you
say would you say the death of David was
kind of swept under the rug
>> you're not answering the question
>> who was also known as the son of God
>> bless are you wasting my time, bro. You
trouble?
>> No, no, I'm just asking you. You just
said, is is God, you know, what you can
So, can you can you So, can you answer
my question, please?
>> Yes, sir. Go ahead.
>> Will God sweep your sin under the rug?
Would a just God sweep your sin under
the rug?
>> Would a just God sweep your sin under
the rug? I suppose, first of all, it
depends on the sin. It depends on your
repentance. How you repent, how you
>> So, so the answer is yes. You're saying
yes. God will sweep your sin under the
rug depending on how badly you cry it
out to him in repentance. and how bad
the sin is. There's sins that can
probably God can forgive. You mean you
mean would God forgive a sin? Is that
what you mean?
>> No, that's not what I'm asking. I think
my question is pretty clear and you
answered very clearly and this is your
concept of God which um obviously we we
we have uh man the God that I serve and
believe in is completely 100% just fully
just and so he's not corrupt. He cannot
be bribed with our good works or our
cries or our tears. He cannot be bribed
with our sars. Um he's holy and he's
perfectly just. And so with that being
said, a holy and just judge cannot just
sweep your crime under the rug. He
cannot sweep your sin under the rug.
That would go against his nature of
justice and holiness. So, but according
to your view, your God does sweep sin
under the rug. It depends on the sin. If
it's a if it's a sin that he, you know,
you know, okay, you know, it's all
right. He'll sweep it under the rug and
just accept you in. Let it let you go
by.
>> Um that's a merciful judge. I can agree
that that's mercy, but that's injustice.
He's not holy.
>> I think the mercy of God. Yeah. For for
us Muslims, I think it's more about the
mercy of God. You know, we don't believe
like it says, you know, we believe Jesus
prayed to God and God saved him. You
know, you know, you know the verse.
>> You you don't have you don't have that
in the Quran where Jesus prayed to God
to save. We don't believe he we don't
believe he had no pain, no suffering, no
humiliation. And we we believe he was a
blessing.
>> Yeah. But why why are you so against
Jesus going through suffering, going
through pain and being crucified?
>> Because he was he was the beloved
prophet of God. God would never ever put
him through that.
>> Hold on a second.
>> God's mercy.
>> Did Did Why didn't Allah stop the other
prophets from being unalived?
>> Because not every not every not every
prophet that's that's the decree of
Allah. Not every prophet can.
>> Very good.
Do does Allah love his prophets? Are
they are they not the beloved prophets
of Allah?
>> Yes, of course Allah loves his prophets.
>> So yeah, so even though he loved his
prophets, he let some of his prophets
suffer suffer heinous crimes and death.
>> Yeah. So
from with Jesus, we don't believe Jesus
did.
>> I I know. But see, notice notice this.
What I need you to do is to stop
pretending like you have rational
reasons rational reasoning on why Jesus
won't can't go through this type of
suffering. Stop doing that because you
don't have any. The only thing that you
have is I'm a Muslim. My Quran says it
was made to appear and that Allah saved
him. So that's what I believe as a
Muslim. That's the only reason why Yes.
That's the only reason why you reject
the suffering and crucifixion of the
Messiah because according to your Quran,
Allah let some of his prophets suffer.
According to your Quran, Allah let some
of his prophets suffer heinous deaths.
According to your Quran, he did let them
die and be killed and beurdered.
So this is according to your Quran.
Matter of fact, this is the pattern of
Allah that allows this to happen. So
stop saying, "Oh, he's the beloved
prophet of Allah. He wouldn't let this
happen." Yes, he would. Yes, he would.
>> Within within No, no, one second though.
I've just listened to what you've said
within within reason. Within the case of
Jesus Christ, peace be upon him. within
the case of Jesus, right? I'm talking
about Jesus, peace be upon him. That's
who we're talking about. That's the
prophet we're talking about, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Within his within his situation.
>> Mhm.
>> Right. I think God's mercy is more than
enough for everybody's sins. I mean,
even look
>> Yeah. But not
can you
>> Yeah. But can you What about Ezekiel 18?
Can you disagree with that? 19 to 21.
>> Can you disagree with that? Do you ask
why does the sun
>> wait do do you do you disagree with
Ezekiel 18?
>> No no I'm not disagreeing with anything.
What I'm asking you is according to
Ezekiel 18 you don't need blood.
>> You don't need a sacrifice.
>> Wait hold on a second. According to
Ezekiel 18 what does God say that the
wicked man should do in order to receive
forgiveness?
>> Ezekiel 19. Is it which which one is it?
Ezekiel 19 I think. Isn't it
>> Ezekiel chapter 18?
>> Yeah. where he says, "But but if a
wicked man, if a wicked man,
>> let me just read it. I'll just read it.
Um, yet you ask, why does the son not
share the guilt of his father?"
Question. Since the son has done what I
just, what is just and right and has
been careful to keep all my decrees,
>> he will surely live. The one who sins is
the one who will alive. The child will
not share the guilt of the parent nor
the parent share the guilt of the child.
Righteousness of the righteous will be
credited to them and the wickedness of
the wicked will be ch will be charged
against them. But if a wicked person
turns away from all the sins they have
committed and keeps all my decrees and
does what is just and right, that person
surely live.
Okay. So, would you say that's under the
roof? Would you say that's under the
roof?
>> Hold on a second. Blessed. And so, if a
wicked man turns from his sins and keeps
all of God's decrees and does what is
just and right, then he shall live,
right? What are the what are the decrees
of God when it comes to repentance?
>> Well, fully with a full heart, asking
for forgiveness, following the laws of
God, etc., etc., whatever you want to
call it.
>> What is the law of God when it comes to
>> repentance? I'm saying is if a man has
sinned
>> bless bless please please don't skip
over what is God's decree okay so what
is his decree what is his law in regards
to repentance
>> what is his law in regards to repentance
within the old testament I'm not sure
you're going to have to tell me that but
my point being you is
>> why why are these being and these would
you call under the rug
>> I got you I'm just show you that you're
not even you're not comprehending what
you're reading you're not comprehending
what you're reading bro this is
Leviticus chapter 17 11. This is the law
when it comes to repentance and
atonement for sin. You ready? Let me
know when you're ready.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> All right. It says, "For the life of the
flesh is in the blood, and I have given
it for you on the altar to make
atonement for your souls. For it is the
blood that makes atonement by the life."
So, what is God's decree when it comes
to atonement for sin?
>> Sorry, just say that a little bit again.
Okay, remember the question is what is
God's decree when it comes to repentance
and atonement for sin? Leviticus 17:11,
for the life of the flesh is in the
blood, and I have given it for you on
the altar to make atonement for your
souls. For it is the blood that makes
atonement by the life. So according to
God's decree of repentance and
atonement,
>> you're saying it's the crucifixion.
>> Just keep it simple. So you're saying
it's the crucifixion?
>> Of course. But according to this, what
is God's law? An atonement for sin.
>> The crucifixion of Jesus. Is that what
you're saying?
>> It's not what I'm saying. Are are you
listening to the verse that I read?
>> Yeah. Sorry. Just You're just going to
have to explain it. Somebody's there.
Just give me one second. Go ahead.
>> But I I don't want to talk if you're not
paying attention.
>> I'm listening. No, no, I'm listening.
I'm listening. Go ahead.
>> Okay. It's a substitutionary sacrifice,
>> right?
>> That's God's decree when it comes to
repentance. How does one repent and ret
and achieve atonement for the souls? By
offering a substitutionary sacrifice
with the attitude of true faith and
belief and a true attitude and heart of
repentance. Okay.
>> So when it says if a wicked man turns
from his ways,
>> keeps all my decrees and does what is
just right, the decrees of God include
substitutionary sacrifice for his sin.
He still has to offer give an offering.
>> Yeah. No, that's fine. So, so, so what
you're saying is I understand right so
according to that verse then they used
to sacrifice right for for obviously for
forgiveness from God right is what
you're trying to say that I get that
that's what he also says no guilt no
guilt will be shared between the son or
the father
>> of course no guilt the son's guilt will
be his own the father's guilt will be
his own so what do you have you have
human beings that cannot atone for each
other, which is why God has to do it.
Which is why, go to Ezekiel 16 for me,
just a couple chapters before. Watch how
beautiful this is. When you're there,
>> Ezekiel 16, right? He does not oppress
anyone or quite
>> Go to Hold. I got to tell you the verse.
Go to verse 63.
>> Ezekiel 16 verse 63. Okay.
Right. Yeah. Okay.
>> And what does God say?
>> Right. Yeah. So then when I make
atonement for you for all your of all
you have done, you will remember and be
ashamed and never again open your mouth
because of your humiliation because the
declares the Lord.
>> So who's going to make atonement for
mankind?
>> The Lord.
>> Exactly. God himself. God himself is
going to atone for mankind's sins.
>> Right. And then therefore their sins
will be remembered no more. This is what
we see at the crucifixion. God himself
atoning for the sins.
>> Yeah. So could God himself do it without
the crucifixion or not?
>> He does this by some somehow some
atonement. So it's going to be a
substitution.
>> What I'm saying is no. The question I'm
asking you is could God do it without
the crucifixion or not?
>> Like he comes and give his life another
way. Is that what you're asking?
>> Give your sins in another way.
brother without blood there is no
forgiveness of sins as I showed you what
the law said there is no forgiveness of
sins the wage of sin and this is what
the Bible says this is the price of sin
is death period but because God loved us
he doesn't want to unal alive us so he
came and gave his life instead so his
justice is served sin is dealt with and
his grace and mercy is given out as well
at the same time without sacrificing his
justice
He is able to be just, remain holy,
remain pure and also gracious and
merciful at the same time in the person
of Jesus Christ in his sacrifice. While
Allah sweeps your sin under the rug and
sacrifices justice. So he's injust. He's
not just, but he is merciful cuz he lets
you go. But he's not just because he
doesn't deal with your sin.
>> Yeah. But this is the thing, right, for
me, right? For God to forgive sin, what
you believe is obviously he had to own
alive his son who was also God, right?
So this one God is basically a father
and a son. Is that right?
>> What does that have to do with what we
just said? You're not responding to what
we just went over, bro.
>> Well, what it's got to do with it is
because this is what I'm trying to get
to is that what you're basically saying
to me is God's literally unalived
himself.
>> God came and gave his life up as as as
we see he says he'll do, right?
>> Yeah. And this is one God, right? Forget
all of that. I need you to focus. You
said that you can't see why God has to
do this or why God does this. Jesus
being crucified. Stop trying to run to
is Jesus God. You're not going to is
Jesus God your way out of this.
>> You're not going to talk about the
Trinity.
>> I'm not trying to run to
>> Okay. So, I need I need you to focus to
the point. That's fine.
>> Good. Thank you. So, let's focus. So
according to Ezekiel 18 and Ezekiel 16,
still God's decree of atoning sacrifice
is still in place, but it's that God is
going to be the one that offers the
sacrifice, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now, with that being said, with
that perception, we fast forward
generations later. Jesus, God in the
flesh, the person of the son in the
flesh comes, says, "No one can take my
life from me. I lay it down myself."
This is why the father loves me. Because
I lay down my life for the sheep. For
this reason, I have come to give my life
as a ransom for many. Mark 10:45. John
10:17 and uh and 18. So, we see here
Jesus says he's come. He's the one who
lays down his life and he has the
ability and the power to lay his own
life down to raise it back up again and
to carry the sins of the world. And God
said he's going to do this already. He
already said he's going to do this. So
why in the world would it surprise you
that it took that it actually came into
fulfillment? Why why does that surprise
you when the prophets told you this
would happen?
>> It surpris It surprises me. It surprises
me because it's just the whole concept
of it, right? Like I says to you, Jesus
is God, right? The father is God, right?
The son is God. So the whole concept of
God going through what he went through
one of the persons literally begging the
father going through the way he went
through it going you know happening
through the hands of the devil himself
right and the children the obviously the
children of the devil being used Jesus
being cursed a sinless man being
punished that's what does it I think if
God wanted if God was the almighty and
the all powerful it didn't need to
happen like that if God wanted to if
wanted if God wanted to a sacrifice to
be done it could have been in any other
way why does it have to be Jesus
>> yeah I think I think I think that such a
>> I think that with with your inability
>> you know it's like a betray I think it's
like just really just really quick
blessed really quick blessed
>> blessed are are are you able to hear me
>> okay I'm going to go ahead and cut this
off cuz this conversation is a waste of
my time and the reason why it's a waste
of my time brother is because you are
not engaging with what I just said and
broke down And you're just
>> so I'm just saying I don't understand
the reason for it. Why does he so so so
leave Islam since you don't understand
the reason of Allah's hands. Leave
Islam.
>> Say that again.
>> Leave Islam since you don't understand
Allah and the ways that he does. Leave
Islam. Do you understand Allah and what
he does?
>> I don't believe I don't believe Allah
would do that. I believe Allah would say
that.
>> Do you believe Allah has hands? And do
you understand his hands? Do you believe
Allah has a shin? Do you understand his
shin? Do you believe Allah and the
reasons why he does things? Do you know
why he does things?
>> Yeah, but listen, I'm not being
disrespectful. I'm not trying to I know
you're taking it in the wrong way. I'm
just giving you my point of view.
>> Are you able Are you able to answer
that?
>> Would need to go.
>> I think that you're being inconsistent.
You're being inconsistent and you're
being hyper skeptical of everything and
you're being a hypocrite because you
have things in Islam that you accept and
you said yes to this. You ex you accept
things that you don't understand and
fully comprehend. But you're saying, "Oh
yeah, when it comes to the crucifixion
of Jesus, when it comes to Jesus being
God and taking on fle flesh and dying
for our sins, oh yeah, this goes I I
just can't wrap my head around it. I
can't understand it. So I reject it."
You're
>> not right. It's not about It's not about
not Yeah. Okay. You can say it's I'm
finding it difficult to understand. You
know what you just said about Jesus
being God. That's that bit for me is a
bit difficult to understand.
>> It's okay.
>> You know, to be I'm going to be honest
with you about
>> It's okay, bro. It's okay. Take care,
man. Have a good day.
>> Yeah, but listen, Avery, before you drop
me, one second. Just before you drop me,
Right. I'm I'm I'm asking you an honest
question, right? This isn't a question
about me trying to, you know,
>> No more questions.
>> As if you're not It's not got you
moment, right? It's not a got you
moment, right?
>> Le I'm about to drop you. No more
questions.
>> But hold on. Hold on, Avery. Man, one
second. Oh, I'm just going to ask you
one quick question, right?
>> Okay. Go ask you a quick question. Take
care. Take care of yourself, bro.